parís 1840 tras meses de negociaciones
con reino unido francia obtiene la
repatriación del cuerpo de napoleón
primero el 15 de diciembre de ese año al
son del réquiem de mozart el ex
emperador recibe un funeral de estado
napoleón bonaparte está enterrado en el
corazón de parís en el hotel de sun
valley donde todavía yate hoy en día a
pesar de su impacto en la historia no
hay calles plazas o bulevares con el
nombre de napoleón en parís cuyo
objetivo cambiando absolutamente pero no
siempre ha sido así
al contrario bajo el primer imperio
había una calle de napoleón un malecón
de napoleón
incluso el palacio del elíseo se llamaba
el liceo napoleón a la caída del primer
imperio por supuesto borró todos estos
nombres que fueron cambiados por ejemplo
la calle napoleón se convirtió en la
calle de la paz con clarín a prueba de
agua y latín
y se repite la historia tras el fin del
segundo imperio de napoleón tercero
la avenida la avenida de napoleón se
convertirá más prosaicamente en la
avenida de la ópera por otro lado la
calle bonaparte permanecerá es la que
conocemos en el corazón de santiago
mande porque porque hicimos la
diferencia entre el general de la
revolución el general de la república y
el emperador de los franceses estados de
jose la calle bonaparte es está a 20
minutos caminando desde el ayuntamiento
de parís
no creo que napoleón realmente necesite
una plaza una calle o una avenida está
representado en todas partes dejó
huellas arquitectónicas muy importantes
era un hombre de grandes monumentos no
sé si hay alguna urgencia en el siglo 21
para hacer una avenida napoleón que no
se hizo en el siglo 19 ni en el 2011 si
napoleón no tiene una calle con su
nombre la sombra del antiguo emperador
se cierne sobre parís nombres de
batallas tratados de paz generales
arquitectos científicos del primer
imperio al menos 25 estaciones de metro
de parís están directamente relacionadas
con él pero también los monumentos entre
los más emblemáticos de la capital
el arco de triunfo de la plaza actual el
carrusel la iglesia de la magdalena las
columnas de la calle rivoli o la columna
de la plaza pontón